*le pewds screams for the nippuls*
woah
oh my gawd ((omg look at dem bewbs))
hell yeah
I'll take that jumpscare anyday eugh
oh yeesh
oh
oh i'm in to it *sweats*
(my body turns again into ashes)
woaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaah
what is happuneeeeeeeeeeng
((calm down pewds))
(and darkness brings solace)
woaaaaaah *pewds imitates pro diver*
shit.
((narrator speaking in such low voice and such long text))
((it looks cool tho tbh))
*le pewds diving deeper for the bewbs*
hey
welcome everybody
to-- *in game narrator cuts in*
--i wasn't done
it just fucken started
here we go
awrite
fucken hell
what the fuck what the fuck can i--
okay alright
HEY how's it goin' bros
so this is PEWDIEPIE HERE
today is we uh--
it's been a while since we just played a fucking game
how about that
this is a game that i'm really curious about
it's called Agony
basically
YER IN HELL
((WELL FUCK ME amirite))
THAT'S IT
THAT'S THE PREMISE
it's pretty cool
i'm excited to guh--
to givituh givituh givituh go
OOOOOOORITE let's go to hell bros (I have a feeling that's gonna be one HELL of a ride. haha. sorry)
if you're ready
and if i can have your promise
then let's go to hell together with me
i know you would do it with me
cuz' you think i'm speshul ((ye ofc))
you think i'm
you would do it
/i/ would do it with you
((aw))
it would literally be hell going with you
((GRADE A COMEDY FOLKS))
*snaps* ROASTED
alright let's go
okay
it's not too bad so far
ya' know i expected hell to be a lil' worse
a lil' bit more Justin Bieber tunes
and a lil' bit moar Jacob Sartorius
and a lil' less--
you know moist, damp atmosphere
that's what i'm gettin'
oh i hafta press A and D awrite
my favorite thing actually
you know what? this is a joy so far
i am really enjoying it
WOAH
okay i think we took thess--
--sssspirit of one of those guys
LOOK AT THIS
/this/ is cool
am i crying?
wow wuh-- i am a bitch in hell and bitch in life
hey lookit that it's a lil'-- uh--
it's a lil'----splash
hey how's everyone doin' here
*woman's voice crying*
how u doin' thar babeh
*woman's voice sobbing*
u sad??
awe don''t be sad
*pewds suddenly realizes that dialogues aren't available in demo*
DEMMIT
I ADDED SO MUCH TO ASK ((????))
((what did pewds say just now idk))
shut the fuck up i don't care you're uh--
you're not a girl
can i see your tits?
they look like that in cucumber emoji looking thing
wow
amazing
i could describe them all day but we gotta continue
HEY how's it going how u doin'
let's talk to you ((pewds do u not remember))
ah FOR FUCK'S SAKE
aaawrite what about you
HEY more tits *womenly moans are heard*
ok don't make that noise???
cause i think i'm gonna get troubles, alright?
let's
UH FUH--
HELVETE ((you're in it pewds))
why do i keep falling for it
OWH lookit that
ew
WEUUUGH
what is that
*pewds cringing* it's so slimy
((reminds me of inside tbh))
that guy's ripping a fat joint isn't he?
HITLER
HITLER U IN HERE?
AW IT BETTER THAN--
OH
find a way to possess a demon
*shocked pewds*
what???
THAT'S FUCKEN AWESOME
hey are u a demon?
oh you needed this?
oh that's TOO BAD
BETCH
what do we have here?
fabulous baby
dude, hell is AWESOME
THIS IS AMAZING, now let's find a baby
lemme check your tonsils
oh dude you look gr8
*CRINGEY MAXILLA MOVEMENTS*
EUUUGH
okay it's kind of gross, it's kind of gross i'm not gonna lie
it's fucken gross
to avoid being detected
hold your breath and use crouch
from who?
why don't you hold your breath? cause DAMN u shtank
alright herew--
ew look at that
that's cool ((why u cringing tho poods?))
who's gonna detect me tho
i hear something
*low growl in the distance*
who's making that noise?
look at the teeth, this is such a cool design
HEY GUYS how's it goin' up thar
i am holding my breath to avoid being detected
*SWEEEEE*
*OOMPH*
oh is that a demon?
that's cool
i can't wait to be
OOOOH MY GOD THERE'S BODIES EVERYWHERE
oh dude--
*woman moaning*
*growling*
WOAH
FUCK YUH
that guy's like "HIGH FIVE PLEASE"
okay then
that's cool
this game is so cool
OH THERE'S A DEMON
shit shit fuck
shit fuck
okay, i geddit
how do we get past it?
alright let's--
oh fuckfuck
OH MY GOD IT'S EATING THE HAND
OOOOOOH
OKAY alright
let's sneak by
*cringing pewds attacks again*
*le poods screams at the bewbs*
WOAH ((ikr, such jiggle))
OH MY GOD
((why u holdin ur own boobs doe))
HELL YEAH
i'll take that jumpscare anyday
OH YESH
OH
OH I'M IN TO IT *sweats*
i'm in to it
in Agony, death is only part of the journey
use your astral body to find lesser creatures
oh i do that everyday, that's how i found Jacksepticeye *wonk*
OH OKAY i geddit, i gotta go back to those lesser ones
oh those fucken peasents
hey Jack a' boy, would you miiiind?
open your eyes Jack a' boy
let's go
this is really cool
i didn't expect this game to be this cool
shut the fuck up
oh god i'm playing as a girl now
okay, i don't think i crouched last time
damn did that demon had big titties ((very realistic boobs might i add))
oh shit
EUGH JÄVLA
*terrified pewds stands in corner*
oh my god those titties
this is the worst tity jumpscare oh my god
stop
it hurts my titties when u do dat
and i don't even have breasts
hell is weird man
*screaming heard*
i'm kind of into it, you know
i hate to say it 2x
but i'm kind of into it
hey are u having fun there
there's gonna be so much censoring for this episode, jesus christ
*crunching sounds*
wait, i could possess the demon?
no fucken way
NO fucken way
*pewds keeps repeating this mantra*
that'd be so cool
that'd be fucken awesome
open your eyes bitch
OPEN YER EYES IT'S TIME FOR POODIEPIE TO GET POODIEBOOBIES
*the poodieboobie scream*
is it werking?
*the poodieboobie face*
*and lick*
IS IT WERKING
izzat satan?
SATAN izzat u?? ((no it's hitler))
oh no he found me. shit.
game over
good game
i died
you can die in hell, how bout that? alright well that's good
i always wondered if you could do that well now we know
at the bottom of the pit, there's a demon there
okay so we start crawling
then when we're near, we hold our breath
This should get us out of the way.
I'm actually scared.
That thing is fucking scary.
OK, I think we've got it. I think it- (gasp)
(sharp inhale)
OK, we did it. Blegh!
Whew! This is really fun!
I like it cause it's so fucking different.
This is awesome!
Hey, look at that!
Aw it's eyeballs dammit
This is like a nice Rainbow Road in Mario Kart or some shit.
Hey, look it's so pretty!
(voice cracks) Hell is pretty!
Good to know.
There is another game very similar to this
which is a lot more subtle
I don't remember its name
Let's show it a little second
(Haunting ambience)
I am so excited for that game
I'm so excited that they're finally doing, like,
different things with horror games cause
we've seen the same shit so many times
I'm so glad playing this
This is better than I thought
Hey how you doin' there you little assless bitch?
Hey! Don't look at me, peasant.
Don't fookin look at me
Alright
I'm coming for you, demon!
I'm coming!
I'm gonna take your body
and kick some ass and it's going to be awesome
Oh shit, it's flames and shit.
I should've expected flames
You know what?
Hurry, hurry, hurry!
Oy, javlar what the fuck happened
Fuck! No I lost my astral body!
Alright fine I'll go back to you
Open your fucking ass
Open your fookin ass
Not ass, eyes. I said eyes, okay?
Alright, maybe we have to go around?
(screech)
What was that?
Oh fuck it's a demon!
This way? Okay.
Use demonic catwalks to alter gravity
What the fuck is this game about?
I press any key
What is happening?
Whoa, okay. This is so fucking cool!
Oh look, that guy's bald
OH hey thank you for that!
Oh! No, what the fuck!
Oh my god!
(screaming in agony)
No this is too fucked up!
I mean it's to be expected if you're playing a game like this.
Fuck! I can't watch.
Hey that's (something sexy there)
How you doing there buddy?
How you doing?
Press 'X' to throw torch while holding it
Throw it fucker-oh further
Alright, where's the torch? There's the torch.
I'll take that.
Did they say 'X'?
I think it said 'x.'
Alright so let's find a demon.
AND BURN THAT BITCH!
Nice demon. Good demon.
Alright they're pointing this way. Thanks for helping.
This is so fucked up!
Everything's so detailed.
I love it.
I'm blown away.
Oh my god.
Oh god that's a penis right in my face
You know, see what happens
OH MY GOD IT'S PEWDIEPIE
I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU'RE IN HELL TOO
CAN I PLEASE HAVE AUTOGRAPH?
IT'S PARTY TIME. IT'S PARTY TIME.
Everybody dance it's poopy time.
What the hell is this!?
Hey guys! What're you guys cooking?
Ooo blood pudding! I love blood pudding!
No I will not give you an autograph.
Ya fuckin bitch
Hey look it's baby having a party.
That's nice. OK.
Oh, (chihuahua scream) Jesus!
What just happened?
That's a living mountain, isn't it?
OK. That's cool.
I must go back- I swear there's been a mistake!
I've been such a good boy!
I swear I'm supposed to go to heaven.
Oh my god it's poodiepie again
I forgot to ask for a selfie
Can I please?
I've been too-Oh this looks... Probably up is the way you want to go
Press while holding torch to chase away the locusts
Oh my god this is just like when I feed Slippy!
Get away locusts!
God! Where's Slippy when ya need him?
Eww. Look at the tongue it's got, like, warts on it.
Ugh. So cool.
Alright, Jesus? Are you there?
Yes! We're getting there!
Oh that's some kinky shit. I'll look at that.
Let's zoom in on the vag.
Did I just say that out loud? Sorry.
Let's try and study this picture
I've collected a picture. Very nice. Very good.
Where the hell am I going?
This is so strange.
What is happening?
It is like a weird rollercoaster!
Hey, that's where we were before!
Brah I'm almost there buddy
Ah! Javlar! Fun! Oh my god it's scary!
I don't like it...
Ok, well I think they need to work on their monster AI a little bit
cause it's- I have no. Whoa look at the fucking floor!
Cause it seems like it just fucking sees you and you're like
well OK you can't do shit
I'm starting to noti- Oh god!
Doesn't see me? He sees me. OK.
I thought I could hide.
It's getting too much. I don't know what the fuck man.
There's fucking two of them! This is too much...
Come on! Come on! I think I did it!
I think I got past them!
Oh my god I can't believe it!
I was ready to give up on this fuckin shit!
I'm ready to just quit!
Any time now.
No!
What!? I fell down...
I don't wanna play any more...
(swedish cursing)
I need to see-I need to see if I- OK
I'm watching a let's play
I need to know if I missed out on something.
Here we go.
So you were right by the demon.
But fuckin hand spiders get you
What a bummer. I hate when that happens.
I couldn't even fuckin finish it.
Oh that's really fucking cool.
Hey it's Santa!
Alright.
That was really fucking cool.
I hope you enjoyed as much as I did.
I've excited about this game. Let me know if you are as well.
Check out another video; I'll link it here.
That I think you'll enjoy. And thank you guys so much for watching. I'll see you
in the next one. Stay awesome, bros.
Click it or else something is going to happen.
OH oh you better click it.
Watch another one! Yea!
Check out my other videos!
That's how you gotta do it now.
Fuck.